this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below more on them in a bit
it was a night out of some gothic horror
in june of 1816 a terrific storm erupted
over lake geneva lightning flashed
across dark water thunder boomed in a
bedroom in the villa dia deity a 19 year
old girl lay awake transfixed by a
disturbing vision i saw the hideous
phantasm of a man stretched out she
would like to say and then on the
working of some powerful engine show
signs of life it was a half glimpse of a
nightmare one most of us would have
probably tried to shake off as a sign
that would have too much cheese and fine
port before bed but that teenage girl
wasn't most of us she was mary
wollenstonecraft godwin the future mary
shelley and that vision would become the
basis for one of the 19th century's
greatest novels frankenstein a
pioneering classic of sci-fi and horror
frankenstein today remains one of the
most influential books ever written yet
how much do most of us know about the
woman behind it born of famous parents
connected to the romantic poets mary
shelley's life from the outside appeared
charmed yet it was also a life lived in
the shadow of immense tragedy
[Music]
fittingly for someone who'd write a
classic work of gothic horror mary
shelley was born shortly before the
stroke of midnight on august 30th 1797.
of course she wasn't born mary shelley
although we're going to keep using her
married name in these early sections
since it's the one that everyone knows
but rather mary wallston craft godwin a
frankenstein version of her parents
names william godwin and mary
wollstonecraft it was a name that would
give her a lot to live up to both
william and mary were radicals who were
as famous as they were financially
unstable the political philosopher
william godwin was an early proponent of
anarchism and a leading writer on social
issues if anything mary wollstonecraft
was even more impressive the author of
the vindication of the rights of women
she lived and breathed feminism at a
time when men mostly saw women as pretty
baby-making machines sadly for mary
shelley though she'd never get to meet
this one-woman powerhouse two hours
after her birth it became clear the
afterburst hadn't come away william
godwin went to find help and at 3am he
returned with the physician louis
poynyand unfortunately poignant was a
product of his time a doctor who thought
washing his hands before touching a
patient was as absurd as operating while
wearing lederhosen poignant removed the
traces of afterbirth with dirty fingers
this led to serious infection and mary
wollstonecraft died of septicemia just
11 days later and no we can't think of a
better metaphor for the backwardness of
gender relations in this era than an
intelligent woman literally being killed
by an underqualified and overconfident
man the death of her mother when she was
just a few days old left a hole in mary
shelley's young life that would never be
filled not that william didn't try in
1801 he married mary jane claremont
who'd soon become famous publishing
children's books it was a union that
swelled the family to a ridiculous size
alongside shelly the younger generation
now consisted of a half-sister fanny
claremont's children claire and charles
and would soon also include a brand new
baby but while shelley and her
stepsister claire claremont became close
friends the same could be said of her
stepmom as far as young shelley was
concerned mary jane claremont was evil
incarnate like if some mad scientist had
managed to cross breed the wicked witch
of the west with diobrando by all
accounts this was hugely unfair mary
jane tried to be a good substitute
mother even helping shelley put out her
first book at age eleven the children's
tale mancia nong tong poor but shelley
wasn't having these kind gestures this
woman had replaced her dead mother that
was all she needed to hate her still for
all its drama shelley's childhood was
enriching in ways that were hyper
unusual for the era actually scratch
that for any era really while plagued by
debt and forever teetering on the brink
of bankruptcy william godwin was still
lionized in intellectual circles this
meant his children were taken to see
lectures from leading thinkers it meant
home visits from admirers like samuel
taylor coolridge it also meant being
encouraged to better themselves by
spending each morning deep in study by
learning languages shelly herself became
fluent in latin greek french and italian
by the summer of 1812 then mary shelley
was 14 hyper-intelligent extremely
well-read and able to run intellectual
circles around most adults she could
also be hell to deal with that june she
was packed off to stay with friends in
scotland for two years ostensibly for
her health but more likely because she
and mary jane were on the verge of
killing one another still the move
wasn't permanent she could pop down to
london on visits it would be on one of
these visits that she would meet the man
who'd transform her life
the fact mary shelley ever met her
husband was down to sheer dumb luck the
son of an aristocratic family percy
shelley was 20 already married and had a
child on the way but he was also a
radical atheist who'd recently been
disowned by his dad sir timothy and was
now hunting for a surrogate father the
man he'd landed on well his political
hero william godwin mary shelley was
just 15 when the poet came blowing
through the family's life like a breath
of fresh air zephyr from a distant land
the teenage girl was very interested in
exploring but it wouldn't be until she
turned 16 and returned permanently from
scotland in spring of 1814 that their
romance really began at first it was
more an over-romanticized courtship the
pair sought out her mother's grave where
they would sit together and read her
works but at some point it clearly
became more than just a two-person study
group so much so that william godwin
tried to forbid shelley from ever seeing
percy instead she ran away with him on
july 28 1814 by the faint light of dawn
mary and her stepsister claire clement
snuck out of the family home and into a
waiting carriage then the two of them
set off with percy for the adventure of
a lifetime for six weeks that summer the
trio toured europe still shattered by
the napoleonic wars they saw france
germany switzerland a great romantic
tool that would later inspire mary
shelley's first adult book history of a
six-week tour at last that september
shelly returned to england penniless
pregnant and firmly in love only to find
her family super unimpressed william
godwin might have been a radical but
that radicalism didn't extend to some
poet prancing in and sweeping his
teenage daughter off to europe shunned
by their relatives suddenly at the heart
of a juicy society scandal shelly and
percy moved in together to try and make
a go of it since percy was an advocate
of free love this included odd stuff
like shelly unenthusiastically having an
affair with his friend thomas jefferson
hogg it also included unimaginable
tragedy in february of 1815 mary shelley
gave birth to her first daughter
prematurely 11 days later she came in to
wake the baby in the night for feeding
but saw it was sleeping so deeply that
she left it in peace the next morning
her yet unnamed daughter was dead it was
a heartbreaking moment in the couple's
new relationship one perhaps best
encapsulated by an entry in shelley's
diary dream that my little baby came to
life again that it had only been cold
and that we rubbed it before the fire
and it lived she wrote awake and find no
baby and just a warning if you're
already feeling rather depressed
children dying is going to be a constant
miserable theme of this episode if you
want a happy story well look elsewhere
only weeks after the nameless child died
shelley felt pregnant again this time
the baby would survive long enough to
get a name william but while william
would stick around for a couple more
chapters please don't get too attached
to him come spring of 1816 the couple
were bruised by tragedy and fed up with
still being the object of a scandal
finally in may they seem to have decided
you know what to hell with this
judgmental rainy island again joined by
claire claremont they once again set out
for europe this time in the direction of
italy but first they'd make a detour
clairemonsi had other reasons for
heading to europe just recently she'd
conducted an affair with the brooding
dashing lord byron and was desperate to
see more of him it would be thanks to
her pushing that the shelley's changed
direction heading instead for the shores
of lake geneva and the waiting
scandalous poet there the four of them
were destined to make literary history
now just before we get into the rest of
today's video let me tell you about our
glorious sponsor squarespace this is the
age of creation think about it people
are online making stuff all the time
people making youtube channels podcasts
websites even online stores you've
either got a great idea yourself or you
probably know someone who does and when
it's time to move that project from your
head to the screen in front of you
that's where squarespace comes in it's
the perfect web tool to help you fashion
the internet into whatever you want it
to be maybe the hands-on site with lots
of opinions and ideas about what exactly
your website should look like if so very
cool squarespace gives you all of the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical nonsense to worry about or
maybe you just need something functional
something that works with minimal
thought so you can stay focused on the
content and not the code of paint just
use one of their quick and beautiful
templates to make a website that's both
fresh and simple once you're done
setting up your website locking in the
domain maybe playing with some of the
colors there are so many extra features
that squarespace provides that your
website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member only areas analytics commercial
options 20 customer support everything
you need really is in one place so when
you're ready to get started on the next
project of yours big or small if it
involves a website it's got to be with
squarespace right now you can go to
squarespace.com for a free trial when
you're ready to launch your new site go
to squarespace.com
biographics to save ten percent off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
and let's get back to today's video
[Music]
in the spring of 1815 mount tambora in
modern-day indonesia detonated like an
angry bomb insane amounts of gases were
spewed into the atmosphere a sulfur veil
that enveloped the planet lowering the
temperature of the northern hemisphere
by around 4 degrees this was such a
sharp drop that 1816 would become the
year without summer that year rivers
froze in august floods swept europe
there was record rainfall in geneva that
meant shelley percy byron and clement
spent their spare time not boating and
hiking and thinking sublime thoughts but
stuck inside staring out at the rain try
not to go mad from the moment the trio
had hooked up with byron and his
personal physician john polidori they'd
gotten along like an indonesian volcano
on fire moving into neighboring homes
but as the weather turned and they began
spending more time cooped up in byron's
villa died daddy that friendship had
curdled into unbearable tension polidori
was trying to get into mary shelley's
pants while claremon was trying to get
into byron's while byron was doing his
utmost to stop that from happening as
the tension grew it became clear that
the group was on the verge of everybody
either shooting one another or starting
a gigantic and insanely regrettable orgy
so lord byron decided to occupy them
with a bit of a challenge everyone at
his villa would have to write a ghost
story for some this was easy john
polidori got right to work on the tale
of a seductive aristocratic vampire that
was essentially an extended satire on
byron himself but mary shelley had hit a
brick wall for days she was forced to
confess each morning that her muse had
evidently carried on to italy without
her with each day her frustration and
embarrassment grew then one evening it
happened shelley was lying awake in bed
listening to the tambora caused storms
howling over the lake her mind was
filled with thoughts of a discussion
byron and percy had been drawn into a
few nights earlier on the then red-hot
science of galvanism this was the theory
that human corpses could be reanimated
with electricity this is where we first
met mary shelley in our introduction
today waiting on the gods of writing to
send her a spark instead
they sent her an inferno the vision
shelley saw of an engine bringing a dead
man to life set her mind racing come
mourning she had the germ of something a
story about a hubristic scientist who
creates new life only to abandon it
driving it to murder a story that would
go down in history as frankenstein one
of the english language's earliest works
of science fiction frankenstein is at
once both a deceptively simple fable and
a deeply laid work within its gothic
pages people have seen an allegory of
the french revolution and the forces it
unleashed a meditation on the advances
of the industrial age even a veiled
commentary on slavery the fight for
abolition in britain's colonies being
one of shelly's passions perhaps more
importantly though it's simply a
cracking read over 200 years later
shelley's story still holds up as well
as the day it was written on publication
in 1818 it was a sensation one friend
wrote percy that the novel seemed to be
universally known and read while critics
were divided between those who thought
it powerful and those who thought it
unseemly readers just couldn't get
enough of it the only annoying thing
must have been the assumptions that some
of them made since shelley had published
the book anonymously and since percy had
written the forward and since this was
the good old sexist past everyone was
like let's just assume that percy
shelley wrote this i mean there's no way
anyone with a vagina could have created
frankenstein am i right it wasn't until
the second edition in 1823 that mary
shelley would finally get the public
credit she deserved by then though her
young life would have been consumed by
loss
it was the 29th of august 1816 when
shelley percy and claire returned to
england mary carrying the idea for
frankenstein claire carrying byron's
baby but rather than a triumphant
homecoming it was the beginning of a
series of misfortunes that would soon
come to plague shelley the first took
place that autumn on october the 9th
shelley lost her half-sister fanny to
suicide exactly one month later percy's
wife harriet threw herself into the
thames while pregnant with his child her
body was only found on december 10th but
while percy may have felt some dark
sense of guilt he also didn't look a
gift horse in the mouth barry and percy
shelley were officially wed just 20 days
after harriet's waterlogged remains were
pulled from the river a real too soon
moment if there ever was one still the
marriage started well enough now her
relationship with percy was official
william godwin reconnected with his
daughter just five months later shelley
finished frankenstein that same year
1817 her daughter clara was born giving
the shelley's hope that their first lost
baby had been an unhappy one-off but no
this is the life of mary shelley
remember one we've already warned you is
filled with endless agonizing sadness
even as the publication of frankenstein
approached she was going to have to deal
with more misery in spring of 1818 the
couple returned with claire to europe
hoping to reconnect with byron in italy
and introduce him to his new child at
first things were great the group found
it liberating to be out of stuffy old
england back in europe where they felt
they could be free but the trip quickly
soured in venice that september baby
clara caught dysentery and died having
just turned one year old the shelley's
grief was vast unnameable it was also
only the beginning the following year in
rome their son william was carried away
by malaria aged just three the deaths of
her two surviving children in such quick
succession broke mary shelley she
withdrew into herself her relationship
with percy crumbling in her diary she
wrote the despairing phrase this is the
journal book of misfortunes
honestly
that was an understatement mary shelley
may have only been 22 and already the
mother of three dead kids but her future
was filled with yet more tragedy still
there was the odd ray of light when
william died shelley was already
pregnant again in november 1819 she gave
birth to percy florence shelly his
middle name taken from the italian city
where he was staying and just to stop
you from worrying fear not unlike his
siblings percy florence actually
survives into adulthood in fact the
boy's birth heralded a brief period of
calm as frankenstein became a sensation
home mary and percy settled with their
son in pisa there they made
international friends and briefly lived
the lives that they'd always dreamed of
ordinary lives not haunted by the
specter of death watching their child
grow in the life of mary shelley this
time was an oasis a little pool of
happiness amid a dark desert of grief so
let's just give her a moment to enjoy it
shall we before we get back to all of
the horrid stuff a short break between
chapters where for the briefest of
seconds we can let our heroine be happy
because when we come back things are
only going to get worse
[Music]
in may of 1822 the shellies and claire
arrived in san terenzo with their
friends edward and jane williams to
spend summer on the wild italian coast
from the start the trip was troubled
just before they left the daughter
claire had had with byron died of fever
aged just five at the same time mary and
percy's relationship was badly on the
rocks half wrecked by percy's affairs
and the other half by the lingering
depression both still felt over the
children's deaths shelley was even
pregnant again but not happily already
in a low mood she couldn't take the wild
swings of pregnancy by the time they
arrived at their rented home of carson
magley she was convinced disaster laid
just over the horizon horrible as it is
to say
she was right the first tragedy came on
june the 16th that day shelley suffered
a horrifying miscarriage one which saw
her lose so much blood it's a miracle
she survived in fact she nearly didn't
it was only by making her sit in an ice
bath for hours that percy managed to
stop the bleeding allowing her to see
another day the brutal miscarriage
marked the end of shelley's fifth and
last pregnancy having been pregnant for
most of the previous six years the
demands in her body had simply gotten
too great after this there would be no
more attempts at children especially
when you consider what came next while
mary shelley's depression had manifested
itself in becoming withdrawn percies had
made itself felt through strange visions
and increasingly erratic behavior not
long after his wife's near fatal
miscarriage he and edward williams took
his boat don juan across the gulf of
speezia on july 8 1822 they were warned
against returnings and storms were
brewing but percy seems to have just
waved the threat away and then when a
storm did blow up he refused an offer of
help from a passing ship maybe he was
just too naive to realize the danger
they were in or maybe losing his kids
had left him with a death wish either
way the don juan was lost in the squall
ten days later percy shelley's
waterlogged body was found by then it
had been in the sea for so long that his
face had been eaten away he was
identified by a book of poems in his
pocket after a brief period buried to
comply with italian law shelley had her
husband's body dug back up on august 16
his remains were burned on a beach
watched over by two old friends and
percy's fellow poet lord byron
supposedly his heart was retrieved from
the ashes which shelly then wrapped in
silk and carried around for the rest of
her life the death of her husband aged
29 was a shock mary shelley would never
recover from for eight years she wrote i
communicated with unlimited freedom with
one whose genius far transcending mind
awakened and guided by thoughts i
conversed with him recited my errors of
judgment obtained new lights from him
and my mind was satisfied now i am alone
oh how alone the stars maybe hold my
tears and the wind drink my size but my
thoughts are a sealed treasure which i
can confide to none but of course she
wasn't really alone percy florence was
still alive and now she needed to take
care of her son without her husband's
income at first shelley tried to remain
in italy in the country her husband had
loved so much soon though the money ran
out percy's father said timothy coldly
informed her he would only support her
son if percy florence was raised in
england so it was that against her will
the author of frankenstein returned to
the country of her birth originally she
hoped to publish percy shelley's
collected poems but sir timothy was such
a colossal penis that he threatened to
cut her off if the family name ever
appeared in print again unable to raise
a son on her income alone shelly obeyed
waiting for when the awful old man might
die and allow her and her boy to be free
sadly she would wait a very long time
[Music]
shelley's one consolation back in rainy
conservative england was that
frankenstein's popularity was greater
than ever 1823 saw the first theatrical
production a play that was such a smash
hit but there would be six versions of
it that year alone by 1824 the tale was
so well known that the foreign secretary
directly referenced it in a speech to
parliament as shelly riley noted of this
period lo and behold i found myself
famous by now though it wasn't just
frankenstein that she was famous for but
for being the last living link to the
romantics yep it's time for yet more
characters to die in this case lord
byron who was carried away by illness
while fighting in the greek war of
independence with john polidori already
dead by suicide mary shelley and claire
claremont became the last surviving
members of the bright young poets who'd
gathered at lake geneva only eight years
earlier to change literary history or as
shell yourself put it i am the last
relic of a beloved race my companions
extinct before me a quick reminder if
you're needed at this stage she's only
26 26 already widowed with three dead
children and a miscarriage behind her
and all her closest friends long enough
to the great villa diodati in the sky
still shelley was at least able to keep
working in 1826 she published the last
man a tale about the lone survivor of a
devastating plague that's now considered
her second best work unfortunately sir
timothy hit the roof when he found out
and he briefly cut her off because
apparently that's just how miserable
that old was after that
shelley's art never quite hit the same
heights again now we don't want to give
the impression nothing happened in these
later years while poor by the standards
of her class shelley was still able to
travel even meeting the marquis de
lafayette in paris in 1828 like a 19th
century version of one of those marvel
cameos despite sir timothy she still
lived in an orthodox life befriending
the writer mary diana dodds who was
romantically involved with another woman
and only ever appeared in public as a
male she even continued writing in 1834
shelley picked up regular work writing
biographical sketches of famous people
for the cabinet cyclopedia a sort of
handheld biographics for old-timey folk
but still in the grand scheme of things
these were the quiet years shawn of the
adventure romance and impact of
shelley's early life the flip side of
that though is that they were also
stable percy florence grew up to be a
healthy young man free of the tragedy
that bedeviled his long-dead siblings as
the years passed a timothy mellowed at
least allowing shelly to publish a
definitive volume of her dead husband's
poems in 1840. better still the old fart
died not long after leaving shelly and
her son enough money to never worry
about poverty again not that shelley had
long to enjoy her newfound wealth mary
shelley died of a brain tumor on the 1st
of february 1851 at the age of 53. she
left behind not just a sun and an
unfinished biography of percy shelley
but also a creation that had taken on a
life of its own from its very first
production in 1823 frankenstein became a
staple of the theater with hundreds of
versions staged in multiple countries
because of this popularity it was
eventually picked for adaptation by the
new film industry that arose in america
first in 1910 by thomas edison and then
far more famously by universal in 1931
and while boris karloff's silent hulking
monster maybe a million miles away from
the erudite creature of shelley's tale
the essence of her story that flicker of
sympathy we feel for the devil remained
unchanged today it's hard to imagine how
fiction would look without frankenstein
so influential was it that its effects
can be seen almost everywhere like bram
stoker's dracula or the works of edgar
allan poe it's the bedrock of modern
genre fiction yet there was more to
marry shelley than just this one book as
this video has hopefully shown she was a
woman who seemed to stand apart from her
own time not just as a literary pioneer
but as someone who tried her damnedest
to live on her own terms she didn't
always succeed but we've no doubt that
had mary wollstonecraft lived to see the
woman her daughter grew up to be she
would have felt nothing but pride
so i really hope you found this video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]